[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Do you
have an application
with global reach,
one with millions
or even billions of users
who need highly accurate,
real-time information?
The database that sits behind
your application and powers
your users can dictate your
users' experience, your ability
to grow, and your
global resilience.
Cloud Spanner is a strongly
consistent, highly scalable
relational database that is
fully managed by Google Cloud.
So how is Cloud
Spanner so powerful?
Well, it creates multiple
copies, or replicas,
of your data, and
stores these replicas
across geographical locations.
For enterprises with
globally distributed users,
a multiregion
configuration is ideal,
as it protects against
regional failures,
enables you to
scale to new places,
and provides faster
reads by having
a copy of your database
near your users.
Let's unpack how it works.
For multiregion
configurations, Cloud Spanner
creates five
replicas of your data
and distributes them
across three regions.
One region is the
leader region, which
is responsible for
handling writes.
The leader logs the write and
sends it to other replicas.
Any write to the
database requires
a quorum, or agreement,
between at least two regions.
This ensures that
if a region fails,
there are at least
two regions that
can form a quorum with full,
up-to-date copies of your data,
so your database can continue
to be available without any data
loss.
So what happens if the
leader region fails?
Cloud Spanner is
built to be resilient
and moves the leader
to another region.
The new leader region and
the other available region
form the quorum.
This means the database
continues to be available.
Your application might see
slightly higher latencies
during the leader movement, but
won't experience any downtime.
To scale your application
across the world,
you can use read-only
regions close to your users.
Reads in Cloud Spanner will, by
default, read the latest data.
These are called
strong reads and are
served by a replica
closest to the user.
If the read is in a different
region from the leader,
the replica may have to
communicate with the leader
to know whether it
has the latest data,
and this can increase latency.
To get faster reads,
you can use stale reads.
Stale reads are done at
a timestamp in the past--
for example, 15
seconds in the past--
and are useful if you can
tolerate slightly older data.
Businesses around the world
are powering their users
with Cloud Spanner.
A multiregion configuration
gives you the peace of mind
that you have high availability,
low latency, and resilience
against regional failures.
To find out more, check out
the Cloud Spanner website.
[MUSIC PLAYING]